we will be playing gta and breaking zero
laws
no laws broken today we're following the
rules
we're gonna give you guys challenges and
you have to complete them without
breaking the law
seriously i will try and whoever has the
least amount of points has to eat a
couple minutes i'm lactose intolerant
i will die if i have to do that the
first objective is to get a haircut
whoever gets a haircut first in the game
gets a point if you break a law
you lose a point can i borrow cars
that's breaking the law okay well i'm
running
wait chris you broke a law uh-uh you you
just cut that car off
no the pedestrians have a right-of-way
and there's no doubt away in the middle
of the road
no there's no crosswalk like right here
i have the right-of-way uh it sounds
like a lot broken to me i'm allowed to
cross this path right here right go
go for it oh he's breaking more laws
right now he's just running on a
sidewalk i'm running on the sidewalk
what a little snitch you are
i'm walking i'm just walking i'm
literally walking you can run it's not
illegal to run chandler look i'm about
to get a haircut see look i'm right here
come on let's go gotta cross here gotta
cross hey i'm crossing here
hey i'm crossing it i'm waiting for this
this light here and it's not changing
okay there we go all right i got a cab
coming yes there's my cab
i'm allowed to get in this vehicle why
is my cab going away come back
wait is chandler already had a hair
cuttery boom snip snip
baby that was a thousand dollar haircut
you just got one point
what yeah chandler already got a haircut
what how
he had to have broke laws oh that john
looked good too
yeah it looked good how did chandler
already get a hair chandler already got
a haircut boys
i'm like so chandler has one point both
of you have zero
sorry i really can't eat mayonnaise
chandler don't move everyone stop where
you are all right i'm not moving
i got two stars for that well that means
you broke a lot i can't jump out of a
movie you
you lost a point i mean hey if you have
two stars you broke a lot that's
i mean come on that's fine carl killed
somebody at the beginning what a snitch
dude before we started it was before we
started the next objective is you have
to go to the very tippy top of the map
i could do that i'm getting shot for
just existing
i mean you should have broke the law
sorry man all right let's go to my
waypoint buddy
let's go all right this is the gripping
content you were looking for
all of us sitting in cabs okay let's go
go taxi go
my guy is just running red lights watch
him he doesn't care
look he doesn't care how many miles left
is your taxi ride
7.0 how many you got 6.5
oh look at him stopping though at a red
light pass this guy he's going slow come
on
he's literally going the incorrect way
my dudes are going the wrong way
my guy's going the wrong way come on my
guy
my guy's killing it
pass him pass the motorcycle there's
another lane
go around why are you behind a
motorcycle chris you know you could just
get out and go punch the guy
no that's against the law and i'm
following the law even though
apparently getting out of a car is
breaking the law yes he got past the
motorcycle
he might be breaking the law by going
too slow on a highway right now that is
actually against the law you're not
allowed to go under like 15
under chris is in the lead chris is in
the lead i'm at six miles
if you press escape it stops come on
keep going don't go going
okay we're good we're good deal of a
lifetime that seems illegal
sir i'm gonna need you to close that all
right carl how many miles you at
uh three he's such a little lie hey
lying's against the law
yes it is we live in the u.s of america
for some reason my taxi driver took me
to leicester and i'm and he's i'm just
talking to him i want him driving like
this guy
just riding on people's butts getting
past people not being behind
this stupid cadillac look at this guy
he's killing it bro what the heck is
going on i don't know these people
me and lester going through it right now
i don't know why well i hope you don't
punch a lot of story that'd be breaking
the law i would never watch lester i'm
watching though
did chandler steal a car i didn't do
anything bro they just got me off to
lester for no reason
oh wait lester's a a criminal he's a
federal criminal and you're doing it
no no no no no i'm not that's got to be
at least 30 points
oh how about you ran 30 red lights then
my taxi driver did it i can't help it
that's good actually continue watching
this cut soon i think it's probably good
for you are you not even going to get to
the waypoint
all right my taxi guy is driving me
right now oh my god
i wish he kicked me out just putting
peanuts on your desk
uh jimmy yeah is there anything illegal
about him putting peanuts on my desk i
left to go talk to chandler because i
thought that i was kind of trying to
bait you into
making me jump out of my car i knew
that's what you were trying to do i'm
just enjoying this nice ride through
this
desert i may or may not step out of this
room for 30 seconds
oh really yeah so i might be doing that
that was a lot let's see if we can catch
on the act
what's going on i'm doing the legal
thing
oh what's going on in here oh you just
tried to punch them
oh yeah carl carl
you have a star punching thin air
that was threatening play the clip back
carl you threatened him with an air
punch
you just lost a point you're a negative
one
jimmy it's so weird i actually found
this car that somebody must have given
to me as a present
for free breaking a window is obviously
illegal carl
carl you now have negative you've never
been a window in your life i have and
i've gone to jail
so yeah guys we're gonna spend 24 hours
in jail this is an actual
jail cell all right i got a star but i
still got this car now right
yeah but now you're negative two points
okay i think this will actually help me
so i just got to go to that little rock
right there and i'm good
i win chris is at the top of the map you
are now
zero points zero chandler chandler's
still in the lead with one all right
first one of you to make a thousand
dollars legally
gets a point how
this game is literally about making
money illegally nope there's one thing
that's not illegal
four-wheeler riding oh jordan there's
rando's joining
quickly join it's gonna get way higher
these kids are sweaty
i also didn't say it had to be gta you
know in case you could just make a
thousand dollars right now in real life
i'll sell you this ring for a thousand
dollars
what's it worth 1500 i'll pass
chris is about to sell stocks for a
thousand dollars carl what are you about
to tweet
i will say one it to me for a thousand
dollars any takers
go go go come on guys chris is typing in
a security code
i'll take four there we go four thousand
i'll believe it when you get the
thousand dollars
all right i made a thousand dollars all
right chris actually
made a thousand dollars chris you now
have one point
carl you still have negative two points
how does this not count
and chandler you have one point yes i do
carl you know you're gonna have to eat
mayonnaise your negative two points my
man's gonna be mulching mayonnaise
hey chris if me and you work together we
don't have to eat mayonnaise yo let's
just
like make sure we're good and then just
mess with carl so that way he eats
mayonnaise wait a minute what did i just
hear was that
teaming yeah no colluding against carl
if i if i catch a whiff of it again
i'm not gonna be so lenient he's still
gonna eat mayonnaise though yeah see
what
no i think we all want carl d mannis all
right what's the next challenge what's
our next challenge this next challenge
is a three-part special first to get a
car
legally first to get a boat legally and
first to get a plane legally this is
literally impossible that's gonna take
forever
i have like ten thousand dollars in this
game so first to get a car
all right legally it's free to me order
done
there's no way to make money in gta
no you're not as well you're gonna spend
money to make sure you don't have to
yes i hate mayonnaise chris what are you
doing everybody be quiet so i can focus
on what i'm doing
what are you doing don't ask me
questions figure it out for yourself yes
please i don't want to eat man guys carl
just bought two million dollars
okay i bought the plane what are we just
by to win right now
yes we are by to win shut your mom i'm
about to commit a illegal act just to
take your bread and then lose a point
and i'll still beat you
what card did you use whatever's on this
account if it's not my account
that's my card it's for the channel yeah
it is but you didn't ask for my
permission that is fraud he used someone
else's card that's fraud he didn't use
his own card
carl would you not say using my card
without permission is right i switched
it to my paypal you did use your paypal
he used my credit card chris we have to
dock a point oh
okay all right so now you're at zero i
hate everything and everyone
playing it you can't get money without
there's no legal way to get money i'm
going to do it right now i'm going to
gamble at the casino but for what i have
i swear to god i was thinking about
doing that and then i didn't i got to
bro
it's the only way all right give me 30k
30k no rp
no i literally just bought a garage what
what do you mean i don't have anywhere
to store this vehicle
this game is confusing where is my car
i just got it oh carl just got a point
he is now only negative one
chris is still on zero chandler still
has two i can get
an airplane though you just gotta be
called to one thing chris
his name is called bad egg why did i bet
on him if you or chris get one of them
then carl is in dead last guaranteed and
he has to eat the mayonnaise so
i i need to buy a boat then yeah oh one
just one of you
has to get the boat before carl does can
i jump out of my plane is that illegal
that's illegal it's illegal legal come
on bad egg
come on bad egg oh my gosh oh my god
he's going
he's at first let's go
i've been on the wrong line yes yes
please yeah baby
get in all right carl just got the plane
he now has zero points what is he doing
what are you doing getting the plane i
got i pressed get out of the taxi i'm
done
i'm not i literally am doing everything
i can and it just gives me [ __ ] stars
for no reason
i'm gonna break my computer i swear to
god i got it chris i'm gonna kick it you
have no chance of losing whichever one
of them gets a boat first the other one
loses and has to
manage how the hell did you manage to
get all three because he got the car
first that was
we cannot travel anywhere we can't go
anywhere the taxi is useless
all right congratulations carl carl
bought that boat legally and just
stepped foot in it
carl now has one point chandler has one
point
and the challenge is over and chris had
zero hey
i just woke up and this is the first
thing i get to eat this morning
mayonnaise
oh yeah oh